it's so nice to meet you guys obviously
this show
the team also brought us orange is the
new black
glow what excited you most about this
script
okay um what excited me most
was how bold it was
how quirky it was but also how
incredibly real and relatable it was
i have never gone into an audition
with such a feeling of freedom i truly
didn't know
like what the heck they were you know
planning on doing i
i didn't like read the whole pilot i
just kind of got my sides and learned it
in two hours
but because of the title i just
instantly knew that
this was going to be something that i
could just like have so much fun with
and originally it was called [ __ ]
teenage bounty hunter so of course i was
like
i can just like do whatever i want i
feel like it'll fly because
obviously like these guys are just you
know here to have fun
and play with the nuance and the irony
so um that was definitely what i took
from it i was just like oh this is
really fun and wacky
and uh yeah i love it uh
for me it was um bowser the character
i never seen anything like this before
uh i was i've been chasing genji cohen
since
weeds and i finally got in the room and
this was going to be my opportunity
to get the same room with her um i had
some really specific ideas on how i
wanted to play the character
versus what i might have thought they
wanted
and i had to either go hard my way or
kind of go
so there would in another way and
um and i buckled down and i kind of was
like nah if i'm going to do this i'm
going to do this the way i want to do it
and either they're going to love it
or they're going to be like yeah i don't
know what that was bro but thanks see
you later
and they and they loved it instantly it
was uh
probably the best audition i ever had ah
um obviously we see twin vision as a
super power in this but if you could
have a super power of your
own what would it be
matty you can go first
i i think that
teleportation right now would be great
[Applause]
i got a lot of people that i miss that
are far away you're one of them
buddy um
big sister um i've got family in
australia
and loved ones in la and i would love to
just snap my fingers and be there
yeah that'd be great
i love that goodbye yeah that was my
answer i was thinking nobody's gonna say
teleportation that's mine
and of course the blonde one says
teleportation
um so i guess i'd have to take super
speed so that i could get there just
after
she did see everybody
everybody i just i just i'd be a little
sweaty when i got there and i probably
have to eat a lot to keep
metabolism up but uh i'd probably go
with super speed
after teleportation because
teleportation is it especially right now
oh especially right now do you think you
could be good bounty hunters in real
life
me maddie
um you know uh i don't like
confrontation
um i'm very sensitive
um i feel like i'd be like sorry like i
know you probably believe in what you're
doing but like you're
like you really gotta go to court like
i'm sorry you know
canadian canadian yeah
yeah canadian too canadian too kadeem
do you think you'd be good at it um
part of me thinks part of me likes to
think i would be good at it but i
probably would uh pass on a lot of
things that didn't sit right
my morals would come into you know they
would clash
yeah i wouldn't be able to just go
straight uh maybe
blair angelica might be a a better
choice
for one to go out and actually be a an
actual bounty hunter i think she could
probably pull i think she could do
anything
she wanted to do but um me nah
probably not okay and any word on season
two
if there was a word it would be the only
word yeah
there'd be a big sign behind me saying
season two
you